[Music]
sometimes in nature animals defy
instinct and form unusual bonds
[Music]
meet a two-legged chihuahua who's best
friends with a chicken this is amazing
that looks like nothing you've ever seen
before
see a squirrel who uses his best buddy
as a hiding spot for his nuts
and join a mountaineer who scales peaks
with a unique climbing buddy
whatever their size shape or species
these incredible duos have all become
unlikely animal friends
deep in the heart of georgia is the
peaceful community of duluth
[Music]
good morning
come on let's go alicia williams is
getting ready to go to work at the local
animal hospital
come on
she always brings along her two-legged
chihuahua roux come here
good morning penny
roo is very energetic he's very happy
he's probably the happiest dog i've ever
met
he doesn't let anything slow him down he
has no idea that he's different
and rue has an unlikely friend who's
coming along too
like rue penny has two legs except she's
a silky chicken
this is penny our two-year-old silky
chicken and this is rue our year and a
half old two-legged chihuahua
and they're best friends
penny is no ordinary chicken
silky chickens get their name from their
soft fluffy appearance which is due to
the lack of barbs in their feathers
we rescued penny from a testing facility
she's a great personality she knows her
name she loves to sit in my lap and and
she of course loves to cuddle with roo
ready to go to work
[Music]
i usually open up the hospital in the
mornings so roo and penny get up in the
mornings with me
and they ride together in the same
carrier to work
[Music]
alicia works as a receptionist at nearby
duluth animal hospital
good morning
here rue and penny are the stars of the
show
hi precious
[Music]
these best buddies sit center stage at
the front of the reception desk where
they garner plenty of attention from
visitors and hospital staff
[Music]
people at the hospital are always very
surprised when they come in for the
first time and meet penny and rue
very precious
they've usually never seen a chicken
that looks like her and of course
they've never seen a two-legged dog
before this is amazing and they usually
just love to interact with them
hey baby tell me i gotta get my kisses
mm-hmm
for rue relying on the kindness of
strangers has helped him get on his feet
literally
we had this custom wheelchair um created
for him through a company and one of our
clients actually donated all the money
for it
she just came in one day and met him and
right at the spot she said you know i
want to i want to give you the money to
do it and she just handed it over and we
had it created
rue basically lives his life in his
wheelchair he falls asleep in it he runs
in it
he plays with penny in it he loves to
turn circles in it it's the only time he
gets to sit up like a real dog
and i think it's good on his back
[Music]
the best part about being the unofficial
mascots of an animal hospital
quality health care courtesy of dr
michael miller
come on in
hello mr roo
rue and penny are an amazing pair of
animals they've been with us here at the
animal hospital for a couple of years
now
despite his happy demeanor roo had a
tough road before getting to where he is
now
rue was kind of a tragic little puppy he
was brought in in the middle of winter
he was seven weeks old and one of our
clients was walking in the park
and found the puppy freezing
and he didn't have any limbs in the
front so he had a congenital birth
defect
maybe that's why someone abandoned him
and alicia was up front and she said oh
i'm taking him this one's mine
luckily for rue his feathered friend was
there to warm him up
penny was here that day and penny came
over and sat down on the puppy and
started to warm him up
and
we
kind of realized that there was
something strange and something pretty
wonderful going on they have been best
friends ever since
for penny it was second nature
silky chickens are widely known to be
broody now broodiness is a behavioral
tendency to sit on a clutch of eggs and
silkies are great at being broody that's
exactly what we saw penny do with rue
the day she met him
following their checkup it's time for
some fun in the sun
penny and ruth play during the day
together and they spend all day at the
hospital you know with one another
if you look at a silky chicken you'll
see that they're not like regular
chickens they've got these crazy
feathers all over themselves they kind
of look like a rag mop they were
originally bred in china and they
actually have five toes on each foot
whereas normal chickens only have four
they both had really rough starts to
their life
so i'm sure that they were looking for
something security and and hopefully
they found that in each other
they seem to really want to spend time
together and be together and when
they're frightened they look towards
each other
back inside penny's feathers are getting
a little ruffled
[Music]
penny's really agitated today and
usually that means she's going to lay an
egg for us
three to four days a week she'll start
wandering around the reception area and
sometimes she'll stick her head in our
filing system or wander under the desk
so
we're hoping for one today
well she hasn't stopped either she's
just going
hospital staff watches on as penny
struts around the reception area
her loving buddy roo keeps a watchful
eye from his dog bed
i think she is going to lay in on
all her clocking
after much fussing around penny lays a
little present
right next to rue
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
penny will lay eggs for us and she often
lays them here at the hospital and even
though we've provided nesting boxes in
dark places she will go out in the
middle of the bed or she'll go in the
middle of the floor and she'll just lay
them and just now she laid one right
next to rue in his bed
you can tell by the way that penny moves
around the room that she's really
relaxed in her environment trying to
find that perfect place to lay her egg
and when she lays her egg right next to
roo it shows just how much she trusts
him
even for bath time the two-legged duo
never leaves each other's side
tinny and rue are up for a bath we don't
bathe them very often especially penny
but um occasionally she does need a
little bit of
beauty treatment
penny is great for her bath she's
actually better behaved than roo for her
bath she just kind of sits there and
endures it and
she kind of just lets me do whatever i
want
because they have those crazy feathers
you can't really see silky chicken's
eyes but they're right in the same spot
as any other chicken on the side of
their head and that's normal for any
prey species because it allows them to
see behind them and see if predators are
sneaking up
at the end of the day it's time for this
unusual pair to head back to the nest
all right guys
we're home
rue and penny have a lot to teach other
people
about you know not going on appearances
obviously rue doesn't have all his parts
and he's not perfect you know he is
handicapped and he is different
and of course penny doesn't care
anything about that
and with penny she's very unusual
looking she's very different in her own
regard and of course rue doesn't care
anything about that so
you know they just kind of show people
that you don't have to be perfect or the
same or anything else to be loved i mean
you can share love with anyone
while it's lights out now for rue and
penny the bond these unlikely soul mates
share will continue to inspire us all
you know we see a lot of things here at
the hospital and i think we do believe
that animals have the capacity to love
and with penny and rue you know we see
this emotional connection and i do
believe that they have the capacity to
love one another
[Music]
over 400 animals make their home at
nebraska's lincoln children's zoo
[Music]
get up here taylor daniels is one of the
zookeepers who looks after them
and she wears a special accessory for
the job
it just looks like i'm wearing
you know not the most fashionable purse
but it actually serves a greater purpose
it holds something a lot more valuable
than you know my keys or anything like
that it carries around her closest
critter friend
liv a nine-month-old tamer wallaby
liv is the tamera wallaby joey that i
have been hand-raising for the past four
and a half months
liv mostly lives in a makeshift pouch
that i wear around my neck and what's
supposed to replicate the exact warmth
and darkness and safety that she would
feel if she were in mom's pouch
taylor's taken care of the zoo's other
animals
but this relationship with liv is
different
taylor is stepping in as liv's surrogate
mom
[Music]
taylor nurtures her taylor hand feeds
her taylor gives her real food taylor is
her mother
hey sleepyhead wake up
wake up
[Music]
there's a reason why this little bouncer
needed taylor to step in as mom
zookeepers discovered liv as a little
lifeless bundle outside of a real
mother's pouch
the baby wallaby had been abandoned on
the floor of the wallaby exhibit and
appeared lifeless
zookeepers had to come up with a plan or
else liv had little chance of making it
[Music]
when zookeepers at nebraska's lincoln
children's zoo found liv the baby
wallaby deserted on the floor of the
wallaby exhibit they immediately feared
for the worst
she was unresponsive
no
apparent heartbeat very cold very
hairless
and all of a sudden as i was observing
her i got
[Music]
one big respiration i thought my gosh
she's alive
and as we put her on the hot water
bottle
we saw her color come back to a nice
beautiful pink and within 15 minutes she
was looking up at us like
hi guys
what's going on
tamer wallaby stay in the pouch for the
first nine months to keep their nearly
furless bodies warm
at just over half that age liv couldn't
survive on the outside
so the team tried to nestle her back in
her mother's pouch
the first couple hops she took liv fell
right back out it was just physically
too big for her pouch she kept falling
out and that's when we had to take it
into our own hands
it was up to zookeeper taylor daniels to
nurse liv back to health
you know i knew it was going to be tough
work i knew it was going to be long
hours but
just knowing that i would be
helping save this animal and provide it
the best care that i could so she could
in turn live out a full life here at the
zoo that was really exciting
like any proud mother taylor's been
there for liv every hop of the way
[Music]
i really feel like a mom to her because
i've been there for all of her first
moments
just like a parent with their newborn
seeing them you know take their first
steps i saw liv take her first hops you
know seeing her eat her first piece of
solid food
just every moment like that has been
great
you're fine you're fine
today taylor and animal curator randy
shear are helping reintroduce liv to the
rest of the wallaby mob
i bring liv to the wallaby exhibit every
day to get exercise and start getting
her acclimated to where she will end up
living and go play now
get out there
okay
she's not quite sure about the other
wallabies yet i don't even think she
realizes she's one of them she's
definitely curious about them
[Music]
yes i know
right now liv only hops three to four
feet but when fully grown temer
wallabies jump as far as eight feet in a
single bound
interacting with other wallabies is
something that's really important for
lib to do taylor's doing her a great
service by letting her play with other
wallabies because right now liv thinks
that taylor is her mommy and it's really
important that she learns to be a
wallaby
liv takes some big hops forward
and gets close to other wallabies there
you go
although liv's birth mom is now at a
different zoo she always comes back to
her adopted mom that's scary
there you go
okay get cozy get cozy
she's used to people we've been the ones
that she's been with so
when she sees people or especially me in
the pouch you know that's the safe zone
that's comfort
the bond doesn't end with the work day
just like a toddler liv can't be left
alone overnight so she's become taylor's
temporary roommate
it's hard to wallaby proof an apartment
[Music]
she's a very curious girl you know
always making sure it's vacuumed because
she loves to eat anything too make sure
there's no cords on the floor
[Music]
come here
[Music]
after her in-home exercise it's dinner
time for this bouncing baby girl
i am preparing liv's formula for her pm
feeding
[Music]
when liv was little she only drank
formula when we first started hand
raising hers up to eight times a day and
now she's down to two feedings a day
i get every last drop
for now it's bedtime for little liv but
not in taylor's room
i have live set up in the pack and play
in my living room
because this species of all these is
actually nocturnal
so if she wants to sleep she can sleep
and then also when i'm trying to sleep
i'm not getting woken up by her hopping
in and out
[Music]
okay good night i love you
[Music]
despite the bond they've formed taylor
knows the time is coming for liv to join
the wallaby mob we're used to spending
you know every day all day together so
when it's finally time for her to be a
big girl and go with the other wallabies
i'll definitely be sad
but i know what's the best for her it'll
be a change but it'll be a good change
[Music]
in the sierra foothills of california
there's a gated community where the
residents can graze to their hearts
content
[Music]
here at animal place more than 300
rescued farm animals are given the
chance to live out their lives in total
comfort
[Music]
from cows and pigs to chickens and
turkeys
there's the spot this 600-acre humane
habitat is the perfect place for some
animal r and r
we get the animals who have been
confiscated from cruelty cases by
shelters animal control those are where
most of our animals come from
funded entirely by donations animal
place was founded in 1989 with only a
few dozen animals while that number
might now be in the hundreds their
quality of life has only improved
among those lucky residents is a mixed
breed goat named mr g
and his all-time best friend
a 1 000 donkey named jelly bean
i've worked with animals all my life and
i really have never seen the type of
bond that mr g and jelly beans share
with each other
when they sleep they're together they
graze all day together they sleep in the
sun together
they spend the entire day together
despite their differences these two
formed a tight bond in a difficult
situation
mr g and jellybean grew up in a dirt lot
they were owned by a woman who
really couldn't care for them properly
they spent a decade together in this
dirt lot so they didn't spend a lot of
time with humans or even other animals
so local authorities came in and
confiscated mr g and jellybean and we at
animal place were able to offer a
sanctuary to mr g
because we're used to goats
as soon as mr g arrived staff members
noticed something wasn't right
we got mr g up here um to our rescue
ranch facility
and
got him into a nice clean stall with
lots of food and immediately started to
see something was wrong
we were completely baffled by his
behavior
mr g spent virtually all day
lying down in the corner of his stall he
wouldn't eat he would barely drink any
water and he wouldn't move from that one
position
typically goats are not picky eaters if
it's a plant they're gonna try to eat it
so the fact that mr g did not eat at all
for so long was really an indication
that there was something deeper going on
when veterinarians found nothing wrong
with mr g margie and sierra did a little
digging
we actually reached out to the person
who had brought him up and asked if
there was something maybe we were
missing and she told us that as she was
loading mr g up for transport to her
sanctuary that jelly bean was screaming
just very angry very frustrated very
scared
that mr g was being taken away
mr g wasn't sick
he was sad
at this point at six days of not eating
he was becoming lethargic and not having
as much energy the team had to act fast
or mr g could face serious health
problems mr g was clearly in mourning he
was grieving for his lost friend we knew
we had to take action
their plan to reunite the two
but jellybean was hundreds of miles away
and the clock was ticking for mr g who
continued to refuse food
[Music]
animal place volunteer jeff mccracken
didn't waste any time
so i hopped in a
truck with a with a stock trailer and on
my way to southern california
after a 14-hour round trip jeff returned
with his precious cargo
would this be the cure that mr g needed
to end his downward spiral
[Music]
back at the animal place sanctuary in
the california sierra foothills mr g had
not eaten in six days
and he had hardly moved
as his beloved donkey jelly bean arrived
at the animal sanctuary
staff members watched on with the hope
that mr g's depression would be lifted
i arrived at the ranch where where mr g
was his little nose was going like this
he was sniffing and he was starting to
look up and and he saw jellybean and you
know you could almost see on his face
that oh my god you know
look who's here
the goat's depression had been cured
i still was in disbelief i
knew that he missed his friend but i
really truly thought that there was
something else that was causing him not
to want to eat
well i tell you i i am not one who's
who's gets that emotional but boy i had
a huge lump in my throat when i saw that
as we can see when mr g lifts his head
smelling the air his little nostrils
going he can tell that jellybean is on
the property just from her scent he
springs up he's filled with joy and
energy and his depression is lifted just
because jellybean is with him
[Music]
to share this incredible story animal
place put the heartwarming reunion
online
never expecting what would happen next
it just shot into the viral space after
that and it's gotten over 6 million
views
a lot of people felt such an emotional
pull to this that they wanted to donate
some money
we were able to get a fabulous new
trailer from it we're able to feed them
for the next year
all based on the kindness of other
people
these best buddies picked up right where
they left off
now that jelly bean and mr g have been
reunited i think they are in bliss they
have each other 24 7 and there's no risk
that they're going to be separated again
certainly had we known the depth of
their bonds we never would have
separated them
[Music]
jelly
day after day their personalities emerge
proving that opposites can attract
mr g is a relatively shy goat most goats
are pretty gregarious but mr g kind of
prefers you know his solitude and his
down time
jelly bean has a very bold personality
she's pretty bossy
a little sassy
she definitely has an attitude a big big
personality
just to see those unique personalities
come out has been really amazing because
it is a story about them as a couple and
then bonding but then it's also this
nice story of them as individual animals
and getting to have this chance at a
second life
after 10 years of isolation jellybean
and mr g are still wary of humans
at this point the only way to
really get close to mr g and jellybean
is with a big bowl of food
the team at animal place tries every day
to build their trust although it will
take time
they're getting to know us and we're
getting to know them
they are meeting new friends every day
making bonds with humans which they have
never had to do before and i think that
they know that we want them to stay
together forever
after all they've been through
mr g and jellybean are content just to
be together again
they spend the day together in their
little honeymoon suite and they will be
over there together for the rest of
their life
it's a new beginning for this unlikely
animal friendship
when people see mr g and jelly being
together you know a goat and a donkey i
think it really inspires them and it i
think touches something in their heart
it's you know whimsical in a way so they
they take joy from it and then it's also
just showing them that yeah there's all
these wonderful
bonds and friendships other species have
[Music]
just northeast of baltimore maryland
who wants a hip and joint cookie is a
quaint brick house
where shannon apple and kate harris have
a menagerie
37 animals all living under the same
roof
we have three dogs a cat two tortoises
saying quite a few fish
jax is their hundred pound bernese
mountain dog
he's a gentle giant who's befriended
everyone in the household
we've had jacks for two years now he's
very easy going he's very laid back
come on jackies let's go wake wally up
come on
jax even has a small sidekick
[Music]
hey wow
a squirrel named wally
[Music]
it was a close call two years ago that
brought this unlikely duo together
a good friend saw wally fall from the
nest he brought him in to work the next
day and knew shannon and i were natural
nurturers my little fella he was a tiny
little pinky i didn't even know he was a
squirrel because he was so little and he
could have been a mouse or any type of
rodent baby
squirrels don't open their eyes for the
first five weeks so wally required
around the clock care
it is a lot of work to keep a squirrel
alive shannon took him to work every
single day kept him in her desk
and would every four hours go heat up
his formula feed him
you set alarms to get up in the middle
of the night to feed the squirrel
it's like a baby a little guy
they had no experience raising a baby
squirrel and no idea if they could keep
him alive long enough to set him free
by the time he was probably
capable of taking care of himself in the
wild it was already middle of winter and
you can't send him out in the middle of
winter so visible maybe next spring
the growing squirrel would have to
co-exist with his larger-than-life
housemates through the rest of winter
without any setbacks
[Music]
[Music]
kate and shannon waited until spring to
release wally but the squirrel had other
plans
he just didn't want to go he just would
hang out in the deck come back through
with it when the dogs would come back
through he'd make his way back into his
room
climb up in his bed hang out there
this temporary house guest became a
permanent tenant and the new roommates
started to take an interest in one
another
while he's not afraid of the dogs he has
seen them since the day he opened his
eyes they were just there i don't think
any of the dogs knew what to do with him
they're looking at us like is this food
jax was very
gentle with him from the from the get-go
he would just kind of scoot his paws out
of the way and look at him and
lick him once in a while but he just
naturally took to him
bernie's mountain dogs are known for
their sweet and gentle temperament and i
think that's a big part of what's going
on here but even with that said i think
jax is a pretty special dog when wally
came into the house he was totally
helpless and jax immediately wanted to
take care of him
a lot of the times we put wally right in
jax's fur
and he'd get all cuddled up and jax
would just you know look back make sure
he's all right and go to sleep and do
his thing wally definitely surprised us
with being tolerant of jax also
i mean you think about it from a
squirrel's perspective that's that's a
lot of
dog coming at your face when you're so
teeny
while wally may be a cute playmate
he's a messy roommate
everything is a challenge when it comes
to having a squirrel as a
pet what's up oh come here
where is he
i thought it was with you come here well
oh he's hiding
they can be your friend they can be your
dog's friend but they will ruin your
home
sometimes it's like having a drunk
toddler running around our house
we go through probably four of these a
year
as much as i dust bust this house
in order to contain his chaotic nature
kate and shannon gave wally his own
space
complete with branches buckets of dirt
toys and beds
when wally got big enough to start
roaming the house on his own he kind of
took over this room this is mainly where
he uses the bathroom by choice i didn't
train him i didn't train wally to do any
of that uh he loves this little thing
the sides have dirt on them because of
he'll come out from his dirt and just
wipe his mouth off on this thing but
it's one of his favorite little pieces
in here
one of his favorite spots and yes
there's a pecan wally has turned the
rest of the place into a nut house
literally here's an almond it looks like
while he hit a pecan up here
up
right here in the crack
the pistachio he's got a nut in stuck in
the chair anywhere that he can find a
spot he thinks
they'll
be there when he comes back
just like you and i stock our pantry
with food squirrels have a strong
instinct that's been maintained for
millions of years to hide nuts for
harder times what's amazing is that they
can actually remember where those nuts
are months later
you had a nut up here
wally's favorite hiding place of all is
somewhere kate and shannon never
expected his favorite spot to hide nuts
is right here
in his best buddy
and there's a pecan
and you're such a good boy
jackson wally's relationship is actually
pretty simple wally hides his nuts and
jacks because jax is a
great place to hide him he's got a lot
of good coverage and he tolerates while
he hiding his nuts in him so
you know that makes for good friends
clearly wally's not hurting for food but
the instinct to hide nuts is so deeply
ingrained in him that he'll hide them
anywhere even in his best friend's fur
the relationship between jackson wiley
is more like siblings
they can get along pretty well at times
and then other times it is like while
he's the annoying little brother who
just wants to play
and jax wants to take a nap
[Music]
wiley uses jax as his personal
playground he jumps off his head he
jumps
off of his body he you know runs around
him
uses him as a trampoline to get from one
place to another
what makes this relationship really
unique is that most dogs don't play with
squirrels they hunt them
even when our dogs go outside they chase
squirrels even when wally would be
outside when he was younger they
wouldn't go after wally but another
squirrel was in the yard they'd chase it
right up the tree so it's like they look
at wally like this is our brother
the natural instinct for dogs and in
fact most predators is to want to chase
anything small and furry that runs but
the fact that wally was raised in the
house with these dogs helped them see
him more as maybe a member of their pack
or another family member than as a
potential prey
despite their difference in size wally
and jax share a one-of-a-kind bond
turning what would normally be a
predator and its prey into two friends
that love to play
wally's the one dominating
that relationship for sure
jax is definitely one of the most
laid-back dogs
wally is almost 100 the exact opposite
he is rambunctious he is
destructive he is energetic
and maybe that's why they fit so well
together
you know opposites do attract
[Music]
while jax and wally's friendship might
defy nature a man and his cat are
conquering it
[Music]
[Music]
salt lake city utah this beautiful part
of the u.s is a mecca for rock climbers
like craig armstrong
i do love to rock climb it's my main
hobby utah for is endless climbing
opportunities it's ridiculous um
it's a year-round activity here
craig's found a unique climbing buddy
i would say our climbing styles
complement each other
all right emily let's go
she's agile
she always lands on her feet and best of
all she has nine lives
meet millie the climbing cat
good girl
[Music]
i feel great about having a cat as a
rock climbing partner she's non-stop fun
the adventurous duo have conquered many
of utah's peaks
from little wild horse canyon to
stansberry island and devil's golf ball
milly loves to seek high ground she
loves to climb rocks she loves to climb
trees she loves to climb people
bookshelves she's my little feline
adventure partner
millie is my first cat
my girlfriend and i
went to the rescue center and she jumped
right up on my shoulders so we pretty
much knew right away she was going home
with us
millie loves to be around people
she's very curious
and she definitely likes to get on top
of anything
[Music]
craig's girlfriend julianne noticed
their bond from the start
when millie was little craig taught her
to
climb up the front of his body so she
still does that and every morning she
runs up to him
climbs up the front of him and gets up
on his shoulders and almost kind of
curls around him and that's truly when i
see their bond the most
from the very beginning i would always
call her up to get on top my shoulders
so my shoulders kind of became her safe
place
and anytime she's scared she kind of
seeks me and seeks that high ground on
my shoulders as her place of safety
like most house cats millie has the run
of craig and julianne's apartment
this is millie's main sleeping spot but
she sleeps all over the place sometimes
i find her sleeping up here she'll jump
up here to get there
sometimes i find her sprawled out in the
tub as well she likes to hang out in
there she used to sleep in this basket a
lot when she was a little kitty but now
she jumps up here and i'll find her
sleeping up here sometimes
[Music]
time for a power breakfast before
today's adventure really
[Music]
it's important to load up before burning
calories out on the mountain
the couple also adopted evelyn who's not
quite as adventurous as her counterpart
millie's climbing gear is minimal but
essential
millie
come on millie
yeah this is her leash
this is her harness what i'm climbing
i have a harness attached to me
and she's attached to the harness with
this
so she's essentially on belay
so if she falls
she only falls this far
craig used to just go on trips for
himself and with his friends but now he
goes frequently with millie specifically
for
catting trips which
are trips with
cats
[Music]
it's already unusual to see a house cat
rock climbing but what is so special
about millie is her self-confidence and
we have to give part of that credit to
craig he knew to expose her to the
environment and now even as an adult
she's up for adventure
julianne doesn't mind sharing his
affection
[Music]
craig and really have an especially
strong relationship for a human and a
cat companion
craig has told me many times that if our
house were on fire he would grab millie
over myself
craig discovered millie's passion for
adventure naturally
when you go rock climbing there are
always dogs at the crag so i figured i
will take my pet so i'll just bring my
cat
[Music]
she just tried to get on top of
every rock around us
so
from there on in i just started taking
her on more and more trips it's so
normal for me to take her places and to
be camping with her and have her out in
the woods and stuff so i'd say we're
just
really really good travel partners
really look look that's where we're
going there's the mountain there's mount
olympus
equipped with climbing gear and a tight
bond these unlikely thrill seekers are
ready for anything
[Music]
craig and his cat milly have climbed
over 20 mountains together
today they're climbing close to their
home in salt lake city to a destination
that looms thousands of feet above
ground level
i go away almost every weekend on
climbing trips and take miley with me
really come on this way this way
good girl
i think milly might be more of
adrenaline junkie than i am at this
point in my life
millie's climbing skills resemble those
of her wild counterpart nearby
just like domestic cats mountain lions
are great climbers they use their
retractable claws and their really long
tails for balance
and if you look at millie i think you
can see a little bit of a mountain lion
enter despite millie's innate advantage
craig takes every precaution to protect
his climbing partner okay we're going
when we're climbing i feel connected to
millie's safety level and comfort level
that's the main thing i'm concerned
about i don't want her to overheat i
don't want her to to get hurt so i'm
very connected to her energy level so to
speak and how safe she is and how she's
feeling
we're doing really big climbs i wear a
harness
and i attach her to it so she falls
she's on belay she's attached to me and
the rope catches her
cats have an innate instinctual ability
to land on their feet when they're
falling or jumping from high surfaces
this is partially due to their knowledge
of their body and space but also because
of the flexibility of their spines
the solitary nature of cats makes the
bond between these unlikely friends all
the more extraordinary
i rock him with militants because it's
really fun to take her to very crazy
places
where maybe no other cat has ever been
okay we're going come on millie
up here
when i'm rock climbing she just climbs
right beside me
my goal is just for her to experience
nature and to get on top of things
but i let her climb as much as she
possibly can
i try to just let her do her own thing
and see how high she can get
there are times where amelia can't do a
certain move so at those times i'll put
her on my shoulders and just help her
get to the top because it's just too
dangerous and too hard for her to to
summit
the unconventional climbing duo tends to
raise a few eyebrows on the wall
when someone sees a guy
climbing a rock face with a harness on
and a cat attached to it it's a
ridiculous scene so i understand that
but i'm having the time of my life so it
might be weird for them it's not weird
for me at all
[Music]
these two share a love of the great
outdoors but a 10-pound climbing partner
without thumbs does have a downside
[Music]
emily's completely different as humans
as a rock climbing partner she can't
belay me she can't save me
but she's just as fun as any other
partner
[Music]
with another climb under her collar
milly's ready to call it a day
[Music]
all right emily let's go
good girl
now it's time to relax and unwind
let's get you out of this harness milly
you're free
good girl
millie is the most important thing in
the world to me i love her to death
uh i wish she could talk for five
minutes of my lifetime it'd be worth the
world she's changed my life for the
better for sure
[Music]
you